ich würde gerne ein elektrisches genau
drei worten beschreiben bekommst du ein
video über das man sich heute eher
weniger beschwerden kann der wir sind
heute hier mit elektrolyten okay die
welt besucher die zum besten unserer
feature ist mit ihren bewährten gut ich
der erste wäre ja genau hören sind
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir haben heute unseren abgelegt
ein hobby aber das kommissariat nicht so
heißt ein stück land auf entspannung
ich habe nicht die besten
ok werte publikum ich hätte gern noch
mal wieder im camp ich bin mit meinem
schatz machen oder ein video zusammen
[Musik]
quartal mit gewinn weiter für
ungefährlich
ich würde gerne mit
ich habe meine schließt genau über nicht
jetzt kommt alles entscheidende youtube
[Applaus]
weniger willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute zeigen wir die drei besten rechten
ohrläppchen von youtube
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die länder gewonnen